[Music]
Christian
welcome welcome
everyone welcome to the table we're so
glad to see you here everyone here in
the sanctuary and you folks online you
are not only welcome here but all of you
are celebrated
here okay we have a couple of
announcements we are having a potluck
immediately following the service
tonight uh this is going to happen in
the Family Life Center this is at the
back of the property regardless of
whether you have brought something or
not we want you to come and join us we
would love that the whole idea is that
we each brought more than we would
personally need so please stay for this
time with us it is a wonderful way to
connect with others and our
community and we can really use some
deep connections
here these candles that we have lit are
a sign of the presence of Christ within
and amongst us fully divine Divine and
fully
human and so now at this time we will
exit the kingdom of noise and hurry and
productivity and now we will enter the
kingdom of silence and Stillness and
simplicity we will cross the threshold
to Sacred
Space a place for prayer for worship and
for
adoration a place to behold Christ the
revelation of God the heartbeat of
creation allow the unforced rhythm of
Grace to find you to embrace you and to
mend your
heart may we all come
home thank you johnine
you guys want to stand with
us clap
along this is a fun one and it's been
very core of our community from the
beginning so we invite y to S with
[Music]
us ring the bells this time I mean it
the hatred Fair the well give back the
pie of my Jesus Take Your counterfeit to
hell then drowns This Means War not the
kind you're waiting for we say Mercy
won't be ration you that's what we're
fighting for the ho SP loing more than
what hell is loing even
[Music]
for if we can sing it loud enough we'll
keep on out and
prises ring the
bell bring the
bells bring the
Bell bring the Bell
move your feet you tiny people you've
been hiding for so long behind your
statues and your Steeples cues that hit
too close to home I got faith to move a
mountain and to watch that mountain move
it's time for words to fall like thunder
sound of Justice breaking
through what the hell is
even the world last in the Hest sing BL
breaks through the
calvary ring the
bell ring the
bells ring the bells call me a boy and
set a son and I ain't the only one was
in the throne room of the Kingdom where
I found that I belong I scared to face
the foress I have seen them fall before
with broken bones you built it it
crumbles board by
board what the hell
is we can sing it loud enough we'll keep
on it
voes ring the
bells ring the
bell ring the
bell ring the bell
ring the
bells ring the
bells ring the bells this time I mean it
B the hatred fairly well give back the
pieces of my Jesus take your counter to
hell all right kiddos y'all are
dismissed to go to your classrooms and
your teachers will be over here by the
door waiting for
you thank you guys so much for loving in
our kids week after week
and um we're going to go ahead and
transition into the prayers of the
people so if you guys would read along
with us and um say aloud the parts that
are in red and then when you have the
opportunity to speak out the things that
you're carrying into this space um we'll
just hold that before God together and
then finish out the prayer together at
the
end Jesus for this city of Saxy Texas
and for every city and community and all
who live in them we pray to you for the
Good Earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it we
pray to you for the old and the sick for
the Widow and orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed and
destitute for prisoners and captives and
all who remember and care for them we
pray to you for the vulnerable the
marginalized and those unjustly targeted
for their gender sexuality race or other
perceived difference we pray to you for
those experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we live lift these
names and situations up to you
[Music]
for the names of the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your
presence amen
[Music]
here is where I lay it down
every every CL this is my
surrender this is my
surrender here is where I lay it down
every life I end every doubt this is my
[Music]
surrender and I will make room for
you to do whatever you want
to to do whatever you want
to and I will make room for you
to do whatever you want
to to do whatever you want
[Music]
to here is where I lay it down
every bird in every Crown this is my
surrender this is my
surrender here is where I lay it down
every lie and every doubt this is my
surrender and I will make room for you
to do whatever you want
to to do whatever you want
to and I will make room for
you to do whatever you want
to to do whatever you want to
[Music]
to shake up the ground of all my
tradition Break Down The Walls of all My
Religion your way is
better your way is
better shake up the
of all my tradition Break Down The Walls
of all My Religion your way is
better your way is
better shake up the ground to all my
tradition Break Down The Walls All My
Religion your way is better Jesus your
way is better
break up the ground of all my tradition
Break Down The Walls of all My Religion
your way is
better your way is
better and I will make room for
you to do whatever you want
to to do whatever you want
to I will make room for
[Music]
you to do whatever you want
to to do whatever you want
[Music]
to here is where I lay it down you are
all I'm chasing now this is my surrender
this is my
surrender here is where I lay it down
you are all I'm chasing now this is my
[Music]
surrender will you guys be
seated today we're going to do something
slightly different than normal we would
usually stand together for this third
song but um Brett's going to be speaking
about lament tonight and um for me
there's something beautiful about the
church making space and room for lament
for pain for
sadness and I know when I was walking
through the hardest thing I ever walked
through it was very hard to be in a
church room and listen to everyone
praising and worshiping and seemingly
able to
just let go of all of their pain and and
just be in a moment of
Praise
um and I started to struggle with this
concept of like is there space in this
room for me to just be hurting is there
space like what do I do if I can't sing
these words right now
and obviously it's bigger than just one
moment right or one song or one lyric
like we're all in different places every
every night that we're
together um so everything's not always
going to line up for each one
individually but I do want us to have
space for each other why why we share
prayers of the people each week you know
why sometimes we just have songs where
we sit and soak instead of constantly
hey everybody raise your hands let's
sing songs to the Lord
sometimes there needs to be moments to
name that there's a lot of
pain so this next song we're just going
to take that space just to name it and
in scripture their space where people
just named it they just said their
complaints to God there was room for
that he made room and it's still in here
you know they didn't leave that part of
the scriptures out so tonight for this
song we're going to take that space
together and I'm going to read job part
of job 23 three real
quick says even today my complaint is
bitter his hand is heavy in spite of my
groaning if only I knew where to find
him if only I could go to his dwelling I
would State my case before him and fill
my mouth with
arguments I would find out what he would
answer me and I would consider what he
would say would he oppose me with great
power no he wouldn't charge or press
charges against me there an upright man
could present his case before him and
I'd be delivered forever from my judge
but if I go to the east he is not there
and if I go to the West I do not find
him when he is at work in the north I do
not see him when he turns to the South I
catch no glimpse of
him but he knows
the way I
[Music]
take when the pie seem to
shed together of the
[Music]
floor and all that seems to
matter is I don't feel you
anymore no I don't feel you
anymore I need a reason to s
[Music]
I need a reason to
S I need to know that you're still
holding the Whole World in Your
[Music]
Hands I need a reason to see
when I'm overcome by
fear and I hate everything I
know if this waiting lasts
forever I'm afraid I'm my let
go yes I'm afraid I'm my I let
[Music]
go I need a reason to
see I need a reason to
see I need to know you're still
holding the Whole World in Your Hands
I need a reason to
[Music]
see oh
if there will be a
victory will you sing it over me
[Music]
[Applause]
now your peace is the
m you sing it over me
now
oh will there will be a victory
will you sing it over me
now oh
lord your peace is a
Melody will you sing it over me
now CU I need a reason to
see I need a ring and to
S I need to know you're still
holding the Whole World in Your
Hands and that is a reason to see
[Music]
God sometimes We Gather in
Victory and sometimes We Gather in
defeat sometimes we're celebrating and
sometimes we're grieving and you are
there through it
all holding that space for us
and we hold that space for each
[Music]
other thank you for letting us name
it thank you that you are God over it
all and we are your
children like we say every week on our
best and on our worst days
be with
us guide
us it's in your name we pray
[Music]
amen will you guys say hello to the
people around
you thank you for worshiping with us
oh Grace and
peace it is good to be with you in this
space and uh as always that includes
those joining us online love youall lots
and uh also I want to mention we're
going to be taking communion at the end
of the service so we'd love for those
online to maybe grab like some bread or
if you got wine or juice or something
and just have those ready for the end of
the service and and um also want to give
a just a warm welcome to um anyone here
tonight Who's new uh thank you for for
being with us I really do hope you find
just a god of love a a Christ of
compassion a community of Welcome uh
here at the table so I want to mention
next week we're going to be begin a new
series uh titled Jesus in politics and
uh it's a whole time of like high
anxiety I know everyone's freaking out
don't worry it won't be um my partisan
political rants for four weeks um I I
really am I'm really honest I want us to
approach this with as much curiosity and
it'll probably be much more kind of a a
framework more than getting into
nitty-gritty of like do this and vote on
this thing and you know I mean um really
kind of asking uh the question how did
Jesus actually interact with politicians
Politics the kind of that social sphere
and it's actually a I think a really a
timely um question and one that we all
need to be thinking about so anyway so
that'll be that'll be next week um but
the title of my message this week is
seeing in the dark seeing in the dark
and our scripture is all of Psalm
chapter
25 uh so settle in because it's a it's a
long one but some beautiful poetry here
the psalmist writes in you Lord my God I
put my
trust I trust in you do not let me be
put to shame nor let my enemies triumph
over me no one who hopes in you will
ever be put to shame but shame will come
on those who are treacherous without
cause show me your ways Lord teach me
your paths Guide Me In Your Truth and
teach me for you are God my savior and
my hope is in you all day long remember
Lord your great mercy and love for they
are from of
old do not remember the sins of my youth
in my rebellious ways I think we can all
pray that in
prayer according to your love remember
me for you Lord are good good and
upright is the Lord therefore he
instructs sinners in his ways he guides
the humble in what is right and teaches
them his way all the ways of the Lord
are loving and faithful toward those who
keep the demands of his Covenant for the
sake of Your Name Lord forgive for give
my iniquity though it is great who then
are those who fear the lord he will
instruct them in the ways they should
choose they will spend their days in
prosperity and their descendants will
inherit the land the Lord confides in
those who fear Him He makes his Covenant
known to them my eyes are ever on the
Lord for only he will release my feet
From The Snare turn to me be gracious to
me for I am lonely and Afflicted relieve
the Troubles of my heart and free me
from my anguish look on my Affliction
and my distress and take away all my
sins see how numerous are my enemies and
how fiercely they hate me guard my life
and rescue me do not let me be put to
shame for I take refuge in you
May integrity and uprightness protect me
because my hope Lord is in you deliver
Israel oh God from all their
troubles it's a beautiful passage I know
it's also uh that's a lot so I want to
kind of right here at the beginning give
you um sort of the the big idea for uh
this entire message and it's this if
lament is the art of naming the
Darkness then faith is the art of
learning to see in the
dark if lament is the art of naming the
darkness then faith is the art of
learning to see in the dark I'm thinking
of the darkness here I'm thinking of the
um the darkness of loss of pain of
Sorrow thinking of the Gloom of
divorce or um just
brokenheartedness bankruptcy illness the
the night of fear isolation
depression or even the the darkness of
what we see going on in the world
there's so much pain right now I mean I
think of everything happening on the
East Coast uh I don't know about you I
have like family out there I think of
the school shootings that have happened
continue to happen there's no reason to
think they'll just somehow cease uh the
crisis in Palestine and Israel and Gaza
and everything that
it just we can feel like oh my God the
world is uh it's like it's on fire you
know it's just a so much pain and that's
sort
of again that's the social element we
have then like I named everything inside
which can kind of feel at times like
enough that's enough I can't like handle
other people's problems you know um and
yet there's the world as it is and it
kind of is crying out for some sort of
response or love or Compass something
from us you it's a lot and I think uh
all of
this is
uh well maybe the way I'll frame it is
Faith then notice is it's not the
negation of that Darkness Faith isn't
like turning a blind eye like what pain
like no I just I just have faith in the
Lord so everything's just great you know
it's it's not rose-colored glasses uh no
faith is it's a it's a scene in the
midst even of what can feel like a true
even scary kind of Darkness I think all
this is evident in Psalm
25 because it's especially for that
ending you might have heard it's known
as a a lament Psalm or Psalm of lament
um laments in another word would be like
sorrow which as Mindy uh hinted at and
named uh the scriptures have plenty of
Lament in them and uh it's interesting
though it's as been noted by
many modern kind of Protestant churches
tend to not really do the lament thing
so to speak uh in fact there's there's
been folks have done studies on this
that sort of as every year passes um
like in kind of modern Evangelical
churches there's kind of a a noted lack
of songs of
lament uh and can even be a little bit
difficult as Mindy and the worship team
is kind of trying to choose songs
there's not necessarily a lot of like
modern worship choruses that are like oh
a lament a song of lament and sorrow you
know it's like H that's a slim choices
there uh but it's not even just sort of
modern you know Church kind of or I
should say kind of more um contemporary
like style of music and such even uh if
you look at more Mainline churches like
Methodist Lutheran presan and so on that
do you know kind of a more lurgical
what's called high Church style uh what
what uh researchers have noticed there
is as the years pass that they um the
the Psalms that they choose to read the
Psalms that kind of make the
Liturgy uh are often increasingly
swapped out for you know happier Psalms
you know as opposed to the one I just
read you know which is sort of a kind of
a
downer and so that's sort of the idea
that I think we get in in our heads in
churches like well it's a downer and so
this can kind of lead to sort of two I
think there's maybe two reasons or at
least a few reasons that the modern
church has sort of shifted away from
lament I think one there's um there's
kind of a little bit of a fear of just
people's
feelings and it's like the scary
feelings and so when we come into you
know the house of the Lord It's like
well let's just leave all that behind
and let's just put on the happy face and
we got the joy of the Lord you know and
it's and it can kind of be this um this
vibe that I don't know on the one hand
like it's true there are themes of joy
in in scripture and certainly the I
would say the kind of maybe you might
say the major note of the New Testament
is a certain Joy but it's like the minor
note is there as well and we we can't
just play the major chord you know you
can't just or else it turns into this
sort of away from a kind of authentic
you know because there is a kind of
authenticity like there is a form of
authentic Joy that's very beautiful and
powerful and compelling but we also know
there's a kind of maniacal happiness
that's like
disturbing you know what I mean the
person who's just always like yeah you
know but you just feel like it's fake
you know never better you know it's like
are you crying right now is you're
smiling you know there just I'm fine and
that's that's kind of what can you can
kind of get that Vibe at times um in
kind of Christian spaces where it's
that's that's sort of what's being um
pushed and so yeah we we we tend to kind
of avoid lament but if you're looking at
the Christian tradition as a whole if
you're looking at scripture then as I
named I mean there's there's space for
lament there's space for sorrow there's
space to to just you know be honest with
God and and say like yeah no it's not
all great right now it's not
great and to and to kind of have that
that sort of honesty in your connection
to God and the way you speak to God and
the way you speak to others in Christian
Community might kind of frame it by
saying what's most important in
Christian worship is in fact
honesty that's sort of I would say like
step
one honesty uh which by the way I don't
think necessarily means you know so if
you're in a Christian setting and the
song is happy but you're not there you
know that you should never sing that
joyous song they'll never do that
because that's inauthentic I not
necessarily but but if you kind of feel
like you're in a place where you just
can't that's okay that's okay you know
that that's where there's a there's got
to be kind of an inner
attuned to where are you and what's what
can be true for you what what's
authentic what's the spirit kind of
leading you to do and to
be and uh yeah there is there's so much
space in scripture in the Christian
tradition for lament I think of coming
back to the Psalms by some estimates it
kind of depends a little bit on how you
you know Define a Psalm of lament like
how sad and how many verses does it have
to be before you call it a Psalm of
lament you know sort of that question so
because of this kind of estimates vary
but anywhere from like 40 to say 60% so
maybe the easiest thing to say half
about half the Psalms areal of
lament which is pretty remarkable I mean
you think of if you're just praying to
the Psalms it's like every other psalm
is that kind of raw authentic not a kind
of maniacal happiness you know a forced
fake smile but a very raw real kind of
language in speaking to God in these
ways I think for example in this Psalm
specifically it's in the lament portion
is in verses
16-9 turn to me and be gracious to me
for I am lonely and Afflicted relieve
the Troubles of my heart and free me
from my
anguish look on my Affliction and my
distress take away all my sins see how
numerous are my enemies and how fiercely
they hate
me I'm just I would I would just be
fascinated by like a song built around
those ideas that like makes it into
Christian
radio that would be that' be fascinating
like I don't think it' make the cut
they're like I'm sorry we we don't play
music like this you know we are your
encouraging station or whatever you know
um in fact earlier in this the same
Psalm verse three psalmist writes no one
who hopes in you will ever be put to
shame but shame will come on those who
are treacherous without cause
there I my own kind of doctrine of
scripture here will be revealed I do
think
um there are C there is certain language
in the Psalms that I don't know like at
least doctrinally speaking if it's
exactly Christlike so to speak um you
know I don't know is it too far to be
like Lord I pray my enemies would be
shamed that scorn and sorrow would be
laid upon them you know I don't know is
that like really Jesus Jus said love
your enemies but uh you know but that's
but that's sort of the heart of the
Psalms though is like you know what just
go ahead and do it go right if that's
the thing that's in your heart in other
words what the Psalms and what lament is
about is not necessarily
doctrinal accuracy you know like well is
that really loving your enemies if you
say that you know it's like well no but
sometimes that's just the raw honest
truth and and that's where I think true
prayer begins that's where the Psalms
begin is not always going for this is
this this is
poetry it's poetry right and what does
poetry it's it's getting at the feeling
side of life and the feeling aspects of
what it means to be
human and so it's it's it's opening that
up in us it's giving us language to
express that
which again we often feel with God like
I don't know God can handle that you
know um no like the Lord already knows
what's in here so open up be
honest I want to come back to this
language look at some of these words in
this this little section of this Psalm
lonely
Afflicted angry anguished the psalmist
writes distressed troubled
shamed it's honest speech isn't it
honest speech another Psalm Psalm
32 uh verse three puts it this way says
when I kept
silent my bones wasted
away that powerful you ever been in that
place of just keeping
silent holding it all
within whatever it is it's different for
each of us just just whatever it was we
felt like we couldn't Express couldn't
share couldn't open up about some some
whether it's a secret or a shame or a
hurt or a pain or a grief or you
whatever it was just kind of hold it
hold it
in it's like our bones
just turn to
powder but what happens when we
lament you see where you start to give
voice you give voice to what's within
like this is why people often turn to
Art to express the feeling side of life
right this is why it's incredibly
healthy to to paint to sing to play
music to to write to write poetry to
write a story to write because it's it's
expressing it's it's giving voice to
what is within and that's the practice
right all Christian worship begins in
the place of honesty honesty not fake
falseness not not the joy of the Lord if
that's not where you're currently at
right if you are well then wonderful you
know that's don't hear this message as
like we should always be Doom and Gloom
and you know of course not of course not
but but the the point is just to be
honest to be honest
there last uh last Sunday I attended a
uh a 25th anniversary of the church that
we left to start uh the table and many
of you know the story there
um to kind of keep it short I I think in
the end we knew we were called to start
this kind of community a place that was
going to be lgbtq affirming and we knew
kind of the call there um and the folks
at this other Church you know just they
weren't in that place you know and we
took months we tried to kind of work it
out because we had deep deep roots there
you know
and I think in the end like we love them
they love us we wanted it to work it
just couldn't it just couldn't work you
know and uh so five years ago we left
and started this community so last
Sunday I'm I'm back there you know
to to celebrate with them to be with
them to you know to
um I guess to communicate love you know
love like I just think this will get
into our politics stuff later but
there's just so much hatred and so much
venom it's like we've just lost
forgiveness like we just lost this the
art of that um and so that's like my
heart is to communicate like I'm
celebrating you celebrating with you you
know like this is and it is a good thing
God's doing good things to that
Community it's not like oh that all ends
you know because we disagree on this
it's like no the spirit's still using
them you know so there but there were
feelings you know it was
complicated and uh so that I go through
the day you know it was a busy day so
that and then a meeting and then here
and then St the table it was just a lot
you know so that night I wake up at 1:00
a.m. just ding you never have those
moments just and my mind's just flooded
you know like thoughts and feelings and
I tried to count down from 300 that's my
strategy slowly one breath in that's one
you know it's like I got all the way to
three that's when I know like okay it's
time to get up if I do that at 300 takes
like 30 minutes you know okay I get up
and uh I just took space I realized I
just needed to get it out you know and I
just I I wrote I
prayed I I rejoiced I I lamented I but
it was just honest you know just honest
and I'm not saying like and because I
did that ever since then you know I'm
just full of joy Lord I have no more
Troublesome feelings there not that but
it was like a it was like another step
towards
wholeness another step towards healing
but can you see that it's the it's this
tradition this tradition of scripture of
Psalms of lament that
that gives me the language in the in the
very notion that I know like I need to
do that right in other words I think
even like therapy and such is in ways
drawing on deeper religious roots to
know we need to give voice to this stuff
we need to get this out in the we need
to name our
pain right that's not like some Modern
thing that someone just thought up 200
years ago like deep deep roots to that
I think this is what happens when we
lament via however it looks via prayer
or journaling or speaking to another
right as we do this what happens as we
name the darkness I think rather than
those feelings of grief or rage or loss
kind of getting stuck within what do
they do they starts to kind of open
up they get exercised they get freed up
and then we can begin to make the shift
to part two you see if lament is the art
of naming the darkness then faith is the
art of learning to see in the dark see
there's a a key moment in nearly every
Psalm of lament there's a a turn of
sorts and it's just a moment where the
psalmist almost always
names like honestly yes this is what I'm
going through this is what I'm feeling
you know even if it's shame them Lord
you know it's like there's that kind of
moment and there's always a turn into a
kind of naming but Lord I know I may not
feel it I I trust you are faithful you
are faithful you are faithful I mean I
think of Psalm 23 though I walk through
the valley of the shadow of death I'll
fear no evil I'll fear no evil some of
you are in the
valley and you're going feels like oh
it's like death is right there pain is
right there loss is right there and
there's this this learning to see in the
dark right again not a negation of the
darkness not necessarily oh it'll all go
away but a but a scene in the dark I
think um as I look at this Psalm it's a
big old Psalm so I kind of discerned
like a few themes here of this trust
which I think is sort of synonymous with
faith and I want to give you three of
those um here um so first thing I can
trust that God will
protect I can trust that God will
protect verse 20 guard my life the
psalmist writes rescue me do not let me
be put to shame for I take refuge in you
and hear it Guard rescue Refuge we
talked a little bit about this last week
how how the the promise isn't
necessarily that God will jettison us
from the
situation right as I named but it's a
it's a God will see us through we might
say God is a refuge in trouble but
rarely an escape hatch I don't know
about you but I would love the escape
hatch like please just take this away uh
but usually the promise is that the Lord
will be faithful in and through it right
this is why the language of scripture is
God is a strong tower we can run to the
Lord is a rock of safety when the world
is crashing in the Lord is a
stream of water in the desert and though
we walk through that Valley that Valley
the shadow of death will fear no
evil but the Lord is with us so that's
first we can trust that God will protect
second I can trust that God will
forgive verse 6 and 7 remember Lord
toward your great
mercy and love for they are from of old
do not remember the sins of my youth and
my rebellious ways according to your
love remember me for you Lord are good
or verse 11 for the sake of Your Name
Lord forgive my iniquity in other words
my sin though it is
great some of you may feel like you've
done something Unforgivable
the truth is
no
no God loves you God sees
you God
forgives like this is just who who God
is this is God's very
heart I uh was speaking with a friend
recently and uh this person
they've they they grew up in a very
fundamentalist kind of Christian
background and so kind of their image of
God is you know kind of the
judgmental judge in the sky at times you
know and and they kind of Express like
they're kind of in process learning to
see it different you know learning that
okay you know Christ reveals the nature
of God Christ reveals the god of who is
love I can lean on that I can trust that
you know but it's like a process as many
of you know it's not as simple as like
oh well just you know just make the
change just believe the truth you know
you're kind of like okay you just need
to convince my subconscious of that you
know there's it's like it's a process
and uh so I said you know to kind of
maybe help you as this sinks in I said I
want you to do like a a little thought
experiment I said I want you to imagine
the most loving person you've ever known
in your
life now I want you to know that God is
1,000 times more loving than them I want
you to imagine the most just the most
patient person you've ever
known God is
1,000 times more patient than that
person I want you to imagine the most
just um
forgiving gracious person you've ever
known like are they somehow more
forgiving than God are they like more
gracious God's like woo I could really
learn uh something from them you know
no no no God is
1,000 times more forgiving more gracious
like this is who God is this is God's
heart revealed to us in
Christ so that's second I can trust that
God will forgive third and finally I'll
close with this I can trust that God
will guide verse four show me your ways
Lord teach me your paths guide me in
your truth and teach me for you are God
my savior my hope is in you all day
long I think there's uh a lot of
misunderstanding at times around how God
leads as I have coffee with people this
is like maybe among all the themes this
is like often on people's minds he like
how do I know that I'm in God's will how
do I know that I'm doing the right thing
that I'm make taking the next right step
like oh you know there's a lot of
anxiety around this and while it's true
that I do think there are some folks who
who hear from God in like almost audible
type ways uh that is like far in away
the exception rather than the rule um
for
me I I tend to be led
by a sense of
love like holy desire there's like
something good or beautiful or true and
I'm drawn towards
it and I trust that that's the Lord
leading me
similarly I also am learning to tune in
to
know when it is
ambition or
ego or fear that's a big
one I can start learning to tune into
when that's leading me
and that when that when I sense that
that's when I start uh
oh this this is not the voice of God
again the voice of God is always loving
gentle leading us towards wholeness
leading us towards life leading us
towards peace and strength like this is
who God
is uh so in the end I
think we kind of have to as Maggie Ross
the Christian magoss says faith really
is a free fall into the love of God I
don't think we get necessarily always
guidance and some guaranteed you know I
just know I'm in the Lord I I think
often it's a it's a free fall into the
love of God we learn to
trust oh God I'm trusting that you've
got me I'm trusting that you see my
heart and you know I am doing my
darnest and and I think we can begin to
rest in that
uh I want to close with this prayer from
Thomas meron and I think it's it's uh
just a be beautifully put way of talking
about guidance he writes my Lord God I
have no idea where I am
going I do not see the road ahead of me
I cannot know for certain where it will
end nor do I really know myself and the
fact that I think I am following your
will does not mean that I'm actually
doing so but I believe that the desire
to please pleas you does in fact please
you and I hope I have that desire in all
that I'm doing I hope that I will never
do anything apart from that desire and I
know that if I do this you will lead me
by the right
road though I may know nothing about
it therefore I will trust you always
though I may seem to be lost and in the
shadow of death I will not fear for you
are ever with me and you will never
leave me to face my perils
alone in the name of the Father the Son
and the Holy Spirit
amen so on the night Jesus was
betrayed he had one final meal with his
disciples and at that meal he held up a
loaf of bread and then he broke it and
he said this is my body and it's broken
for you and then he held up a cup of
wine he said this is my blood it's shed
for you whenever you eat this bread
whenever you drink this cup remember me
so as we come to the table of the Lord
tonight as we take in the body of Christ
and the bread the blood of Christ in the
wine may it be a moment for honest
speech may it be a moment for lament it
be a moment for praise may be a moment
for faith and trust that the Lord is
good
so the way we'll participate in
community tonight we'll go just row by
row starting here from the front working
our way back and forming a line right
here we practice what's called an Open
Table meaning if you're here tonight and
something in you wants to connect with
the Risen Jesus even if you maybe don't
have like any you know doctrinal
teaching or whatever um but something in
you wants to to do that then you're
welcome to to participate uh just know
um that the red is wine the white is
grape juice and then finally you can
just partake whenever and however you'd
like some folks like to come and kneel
here at the front others like to return
to their seats um just know no one will
like lead you through the exact moment
of taking the elements so this is the
table not of the church but of the
Lord and it's made ready for those who
love him and for those who want to love
him more so
come you who have much
faith and you who have little you who've
been here often and you who have not
been here
long you who have tried to
follow and you who have
failed come come because it's the Lord
Jesus himself who invites you and it's
his will that those who want to meet him
should meet and here come to the table
[Music]
we're going to close with a song that we
haven't done before here um if you guys
would stand though with us we would like
to sing this one Al together um it's
called
Gyra and I love that it names the pain
and has room for the limit but it also
moves towards this Spirit of trust um
like Brett was talking about tonight and
kind of holds both of those things hand
in hand so if you guys um as you're as
you're picking up on it maybe if it's
the first time you've heard it um you're
welcome to to sing it along with us or
um just take in the words and um I hope
that it is a blessing to this community
tonight
[Music]
I'll never be more loved than I am right
now wasn't holding you up so there's
nothing I can do to let you
down it doesn't take a
trophy to make you proud
I'll never be more love than I am right
now going through a storm but I won't go
down I hear your voice carried in the
rhym of the wind to call me
out you would cross an ocean so I
wouldn't
Dr you've never been closer than you are
right
[Music]
now you are
now and I will be
content in every
circumstance you
are you are n
forever enough always enough more than
enough forever enough more is enough
more
enough I don't want to
forget how I feel right now on the
mountain top I can see so clear what
it's all
about so St by my side when the Sun goes
down don't want to forget how I feel
right
now you are
[Music]
G you are
enough you are
enough and I will be content
every
circumstance you
[Music]
are you are
enough never
enough
[Music]
enough already
love I'm already chosen
I know who I
[Music]
am I know what you
spoken I'm already
L more than I can
imagine and that is
enough let's sing that again I'm already
love I'm already
chosen I know who I am
I know what you
spoke I'm already
Lov more than I can
imagine and that is
enough I'm already loved I'm already
loved I'm already
chosen I know who I
am I know what you so
I'm already
love more than I can
imagine and that is
enough I'm already love I'm already
love I'm already
chosen I know who I
am and I know what you
so I'm already
love more than I can
imagine yeah there is
enough that is
enough cuz you are a tri
you are
[Music]
enough
chra you are
enough and I will be
content in every
[Music]
circumstance you are
well thank you all so much for being
with us this evening if you're new we
would love for you to fill out a
visitor's card uh you can do that online
or over at the little table as you go
out the door uh this will allow us to
follow up with you to answer any
questions that you might have and just
say thank you for visiting us today
uh my name is Janine and if you are in
need of prayer a hug or any general kind
of support you can look for me both here
and at the potluck and I will be happy
to uh be with you however I can
generosity is a key aspect of the life
of adoration and worship to give
financially you can scan the QR code or
you can visit theable tx.org now don't
forget that there is enough for all of
us at the potluck so I hope to see you
there all right now let me send you into
your week with this blessing you can
hold your hands out in a posture to
receive or you can just open your hearts
to these
words you are a child of
God you you are a child of God this is
true on your very best day and it is
also true on your worst day so as you go
into the into your week with it's yet to
be determined highs and lows and
everything in between go filled with the
assurance that you are loved that you
are worthy that you are accepted just as
you are and go filled with God's holy
Holy Spirit and the desire to extend
these same Gifts of Grace and
unconditional love to everyone you come
in contact with be blessed I'll see some
of you at the potluck and the rest of
you I'll see you next
[Music]
Sunday
J you are now
[Music]
you
are I will be
content in every
circumstance you are in
[Music]
another one